are these gold they're 23-karat gold
which is kind of an 23 how do you know
how the [ __ ] do you notice car come on
man
oh it says it'll looky looky looky looky
here
damn look at the time broke my [ __ ]
see the time hey man listen family eat
lobster for break fell oh my god you can
pull up on folk like we're going on
shoot me
what you've been doing trying to get it
like you bro if y'all don't notice my
man tell them who you are man might be
the guy to change your life oh look what
I probably bought a couple of hundred
sales from you that's right you know we
should do first we should pre-authorize
the credit card I'm so sick of you on my
credit card a little reason why I keep
switching credit card me I know are you
ready for the sound the changes you're
so listen this is a nice vintage even
that little nice bag yeah you like that
you know that's supposed to hit they
like that I supposed to have that
awesome why do that again just do it
again started all right mister not gonna
join how long a wait let's make it let's
make it up let's make it up let's make
it from memory
let's sound the wealth oh you got trains
and rolls in the blue dude I got car you
flex the boy I got cars outside
oh man cheap manually Lexington elbow
seat and player I'm so excited about
this right here and this really means a
lot
24 karat gold Hilton's Hamiltons what
you mean like the Hilton's no so this is
a hand if Rose does your nose is crooked
that's okay
my man lobstery of it I must break this
I love when your phone oh you know we
don't have phones and ears you have to
trust me or go to [ __ ] LensCrafters
up first of all don't trust every clear
metal don't Russian that's a specialty
Flash gold lens remember the deal we had
you could take whatever you want but in
another eight years my son turns 13 and
when you're prepared to rap at the bar
mitzva you see you should have mindset
of this guy got you're just thinking
eight years ahead you're trying to
perform at his rich bratty little sons
you know to kiss my grandma look our
kitchen girl oh oh you know our kids
granted we're gonna continue with the
heritage Jean PUD would see Jean Paul
what's here we could do promote somebody
now I got somebody muna you only have
the black ones but now you're making
more money so you got the money green
you noticed that we eating over here for
lobster for breakfast I'm kind of listen
man for us these they feel like they fit
my face so well y'all getting this
vertical and
and laughing oh my god don't I have
something like these - no but you will a
table I can a [ __ ] you bro you go most
popular by vanilla ice
yeah yeah I never thought I would
anything vanilla eyes had offer but
these are dope Israel Israel my ID
Huggle is how we've killed I have over
two million followers and I wanted to
try to inspire the culture different
pieces of Iowa I was quick little
earrings on the side to pop were those
oh [ __ ] really
mmm you know what these are come on
those are caught yeah talk to you copped
it close but we're getting [ __ ] should
it be the in their nose no nose oh I
mean it would be like someone calling
you to Cannes okay no one ever [ __ ]
call me to interview for that but you
have another roll bro I mean dude we got
Rose on Rose on Rose on Rose this is the
most expensive stock glass in the whole
entire world
there's a 23-karat vintage Gucci class
before the murders in the house with the
old house craft before the woman and
this is the rarest stock class of woah
that was the craziest thing I've seen
everyone and dude now I can't you see I
mean I can see it in the middle you know
I can't see that way and put him up to a
light you put a light you time like this
dang in the milk as a house crust primer
free goose free murder cream murders and
by me lightness that respect scared I
don't know nothing scares me because I
think leave your credit card on file can
you tell the people of American count
places like then watch how much of these
12,000 us right that's without tricking
them out at all that's crazy yeah so you
have glasses that cost more than these
I do wear chains and I came from
different places mmm used to have these
books where we would hide yeah various
thank you you're a very creative bro
come out here oh [ __ ]
and blobbies I only want to touch them
so we tricked out a pair of gazelles
Isaiah 951 2050 one 1001 the hammer
would be yeah this is your custom of
gold and diamond edition and since I
knew you were gonna put them on and flex
on me I had to come prepared selects on
you listen that's not a solution if the
dare start Gooch's were 12,000 and how
much of these 25 25 bands but I only
gave you the 25,000 won because I wanted
to wear the 50 yours the 57 0 probably
the most iconic class of the made
actually one by DMC Run DMC say Run DMC
feel under something I am I love it you
know one thing a bum I wish I'd shot on
the glasses first cuz once they came up
your big-ass head it's a lot of
knowledge stood right I mean how many
dimes are how many cares is this you
know thanks 42 put 42 kerosene face fan
had the place-kicking like Fanta so
every star I can like that I like to
Howard already get another couple lines
we could do a jingle your phone's quick
man please
hey what can I say it's my man that's my
man right Corey
jenavian do flair for vintage things now
[ __ ] glasses that you here for fifty
thousand homie to haul me boy to boy
I'm not gonna do nothing with that I'm
not gonna place no beer - you bruh
- you but I did place the order for two
more new shades and just for the
shameless plug
I'm gonna need them on the house home
you already know what it is